make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and after making the video on
isaiah bradley explained
which did way better than i thought it
would if i'm being honest with you guys
i thought it would be like the john
walker video where it kind of peters
along and then just explodes one day
right like i mean i think i made that
video
on like a like a tuesday or something
and then by the time everybody got
around
to watching that episode of uh of falcon
and winter soldier people started
searching for
for john walker and it just blew up on
youtube right it was it was nuts i was
like
wow okay cool so like that's the name of
the game right like go back to the days
when i would make characters that people
were referencing in
the movies and tv shows everybody knows
what in the world's going on right it's
the foundation of comics explained
so the the you know look into the
comments because i do read your all's
comments you guys really want me to do
truth red white and black
right so we're going to cover this we're
going to split it into two videos
because it's seven issues long
but uh we're gonna cover this right like
today and tomorrow maybe on wednesday
or at least maybe on like thursday we'll
do the second half right because
there's an important story that comes
out tomorrow that has to do with king
and black but this basically covers the
story of isaiah bradley right how isaiah
bradley became captain america
in marvel comics now some of the stuff
that we have here is not overly
important and the fact the first
issue is not the most important thing
ever right all the first issue does is
kind of lay the groundwork for a lot of
these guys right so like isaiah bradley
and his wife faith
that they share a very close
relationship right it's one of these
things where they're kind of depicted uh
in the sense that like at this point in
time
that it's rough to be a black american
in america and so in a lot of ways it
kind of goes or points toward the notion
of like the black community
in a lot of ways kind of being
tight-knit in the sense that it's almost
one of those
i wouldn't really call it gatekeeping
but it's one of those like you know we
kind of keep to ourselves like we look
out for our own in our community that
kind of a thing right and there's
actually a reason for that because
towards the end of this video we'll talk
about something called the red summer of
1919 which if you've never heard of that
it's an actual thing and it is bananas
it was it's one of the craziest moments
in the history of the united states
but uh in the end like what you have is
just kind of a rotating
cast of people right just these these
various individuals the crazy thing
about this is not all of them matter but
one of the most important people that
matters here is a guy by the name of
sergeant luke evans now sergeant luke
evans is a guy who's kind of depicted
us as a well previously a captain in the
us military but ultimately he ended up
standing up for
a fellow black soldier who was being and
by all standards of measurement abused
in the military
and so when that happened because it was
considered insubordination he was
demoted down to the
down to the rank of sergeant the crazy
thing about this is that he was facing
this moment of crisis when he was
actually looking at killing himself
right you know he didn't really seem you
know didn't really feel like he had much
of a purpose in the military now
i can't really speak for the
psychological drive behind this i was
never a member of the military so i
don't really know
how the the proposition of being
deranked in the military from like a
captain down to a sergeant how that
impacts a person mentally i know that
there are people out there who just kind
of look at the military as means to an
end
and i know there are people out there
that are like that's their life right so
i don't
i can't really speak to how this impacts
people psychologically i'm not qualified
for that so i will leave that to
somebody who's experienced life in the
military uh post your comments down
below because i'm actually really
fascinated
to know how that impacts a person if it
really does at all but the the
change of heart and the idea of like
deterring himself from suicide comes in
the attack on pearl harbor
in december of 1941 and this basically
seems to kind of
provide renewed interest or renewed
vigor for luke evans which sort of sends
him forward now following that
you kind of go into this this notion of
like these guys by whatever man or
whatever means taking these different
walks of life that ultimately lead them
to enlisting in the military and so what
ends up happening is they're all
basically
transferred to camp cathcart in
mississippi in 1942
and this is one of those instances where
what you have is effectively two
battalions or different groups right and
that's how it was back then that you had
black americans who were trained in one
group and then you had white americans
who were trained in another by the time
segregation came along that began to
change and you saw like black americans
and white americans being
you know desegregated and thrown into a
particular group
where you basically had them all being
trained in the military together which
led to a lot of issues it led to a lot
of problems in terms of how race
relations were playing out so
of course you know that's that's not
really something that you see here
because it takes place long before that
but an interesting the conversation
that goes on here is between a guy by
the name of dr reinstein and a guy by
the name of
william price and william price is
basically the guy who kind of leads this
whole this whole situation he's got his
own motivations his own schemes but
you've also got dr reinhardt now dr
reinhard is basically put here as a guy
who is looking to
recreate the super soldier serum there's
a lot more to him than that and we'll
talk about that unfortunately you don't
really see a lot of him
in the in the beginning i don't know why
i said reinhardt weinstein you don't see
a whole lot of rhinestone here in the
beginning there's a little discussion
but the long and short of it is that he
wants
all the he wants 300 black american
soldiers right that's what he wants
300 black soldiers to use for what
amounts to
effectively an experiment and that's one
of the crazy things that goes on here is
that where you have this conversation
between reinstein and a guy named mr
tully but while they're basically
talking to a major
they talk about something called the
black vine and the black vine is
basically this concept that exists that
even now still exists where you do have
like the grapevine right so like the
rumor mill where you have like you know
oh i heard this or i heard that or
something on those lines but within the
black community
because of black community was so
tight-knit at the time and to a degree
still is today that there's kind of the
the black vine in the sense that like
only black individuals share rumors with
other black individuals
right like you won't believe what i
heard or something like that and they
usually you know would exclude anybody
else who was not part of the black
community now what this has to do with
the bigger picture you know become more
significant later on down the line it's
actually a concept they intend to use
for their own ends but the important
takeaway from this
is that you basically end up having them
saying like we want to utilize this
concept of the black vine
and that even like the fuhrer himself in
germany kind of idolizes this notion of
like the black community keeping things
to themselves
and not really having any conversation
with white americans which basically
leaves
white americans completely oblivious to
what's going on within the black
community
the the gist here and the important
thing here is that because of the fact
that the the notion of the black vine is
intriguing to reinstein and mr tully and
they're talking about the notion of
using
you know this this kind of idea in the
military it leads the major to believe
that like they want to train black
individuals as counter spies now the the
thing about this is that at that point
in time in the military it you know from
what i've been able to gather black
americans were largely used not
necessarily as cannon fodder but they
were never really given like higher
ranking roles right it was never one of
those things of like we'll send black
americans in as spies or if they did
they would just kind of be like throw
away missions or something along those
lines there was a lot of disrespect and
a lot of
uh glass ceiling that was going on with
regards to like black members in the
military at that point the tuskegee
experiments are a perfect example of
that right like giving black individual
syphilis and then just seeing what
happens if it goes untreated right that
kind of a thing and so what ends up
happening is that
in camp cathcart at 2 300 hours right at
11 p.m
that everybody's kind of brought
together right all these guys are or you
know all these soldiers are basically
brought in
uh and effectively lined up and what you
end up having is totally and weinstein
who show up and they talk to the mayor
and then you have basically price like
colonel price who shows up and when
price shows up here
that it's kind of like okay uh one thing
to understand here is that one
camp cathcart doesn't exist it never
existed we made it up
and two like tully and reinstein are
military intelligence
they work for me they kill the major on
the spot and then immediately line up
all these black soldiers and say okay
every like we need 300 of you guys get
in the buses you know and the others
remain behind
and so of course isaiah bradley and a
few of these other guys are among the
300 that are thrown in these
transport vehicles and then as they're
leaving all the other soldiers who are
left behind
are shot and killed right they're just
executed by these guys and so from there
what ends up happening is immediately
following that
the entire group as it was taken by uh
the major in
in tully and reinstein that a cover is
essentially issued right where they
basically send out blanket letters to
all the members of their families
military
appearances and the whole nine yards
saying like they died in a bombing right
like
they died to bombing gone wrong and
that's it right that's basically all it
was
but for project super soldier the
location is one classified and two
that's why these 300 guys are here
because reinstein is basically the
science head and he's here for the
purpose of essentially
giving these guys a super soldier
formula or at least a variation of it
and trying to create more captain
america now a lot of the things as
they're depicted here are basically a
reflection of the time so for example
you have uh you have christ
who's saying like okay like we need a
whole bunch of negro blood right because
as far as the ideology was back at that
point in time there was actually a
difference between black blood and white
blood that's what people believed back
then right and the funny thing is
there's people who still believe it now
right like imagine that
right you know the belief that there's a
difference between black blood and white
blood right i mean you know people
people who believe that
i don't i don't know what to say right
they're you know it's
i don't know it's it's it's i don't know
it's just uh
you can't take people like that
seriously right but like at that point
in time
that's what people believed right that's
how backwards american philosophy was
and so one of the things that's kind of
kind of crazy is they actually start
talking about reinstein who believes
that there is no difference between
black and white blood because there's
not
there there really isn't but you know
it's one of those things where it's kind
of like we'll keep that under wraps
right like we'll just kind of let the
world continue believing that there's a
big difference the important thing here
and the takeaway from this
is that every one of these soldiers
right all 300 of them were basically
taken into different observation rooms
systematically they were lined up they
were given an injection of the super
soldier serum as it had been created by
by reinstein to see what would happen in
order to see if they would actually
become
a super soldier and the experiments were
pretty gruesome right like one of the
guys for example is given five cc's of
the serum which proves to be too much it
overloads his body and he quite
literally
explodes you know while all that's going
on again like all these letters are
being sent out to these different people
but when you get to faith's wife
and and the the statement is made to her
hey like your husband has died in a
bombing
she doesn't believe it she's like i want
to see the body like i want to see the
body of my husband right like i need
that kind of closure now understand
it's not because she's skeptical of the
military it's because she simply just
wants closure right like
i want to see the body of my husband but
she's constantly told like the cask is
closed right we don't recommend
that you see the body of your husband
now of course isaiah along with a
handful of other guys are given the
injection of the super soldier serum and
they become super soldiers it basically
ends up working but when the body of
isaiah bradley is shown to his wife
faith we don't really initially see what
it is that she sees she's just totally
flabbergasted by it and so what you end
up having
is these these really only individuals
who survived rights like these seven
guys who lived through the super soldier
process
everybody else is dead right so 293
black soldiers died in the
super soldier experiments under the the
government's version i guess the the
reworked version of project rebirth that
these guys are basically
taking on a series of missions right now
one of the things that happens is that
for one of the guys maurice
his father basically ends up killing his
wife and then killing himself
right because of the experience of
losing his family while that goes on you
then have sergeant evans who starts
talking about something called the red
summer now this is one of the most
interesting aspects of this story
because sergeant evans is one of these
guys who was a part of this or at least
puts on the perception that he was a
part of it and he says it was basically
the war at home right now here's the
reality of the summer of 1919 right the
red summer of 1919. uh it's
it's wildly complex and it's far more
than we can cover here in this video but
the long and short of it
is that it was basically this
summer-wide massacre of black americans
across the united states it was the
single closest the united states ever
came
to a full-on race-based civil war in the
u.s
and the reason why is because you had a
series of things that were taking place
for example society across the board at
the time while you know with the
exception of the most progressive
individuals kind of had this mentality
that as long as black americans stayed
in the south and kind of quote unquote
stayed in their
place that more or less everything was
good and this came to fruition by way of
the fact that in the aftermath of world
war one
that you saw a lot of veterans who were
coming back to the united states and
then in turn you saw like what was
called the great migration which was a
whole host of black americans
basically leaving the south due to the
lack of job opportunities equal rights
things like that
and moving to the north and so in
chicago for example the population
exploded by like 148
this gave way to a huge amount of fear
among white americans the black
americans were taking job opportunities
right they were taking economic gains
different things like that
and so this anxiety boiled over into
fear now understand that was not the
only reason why it happened there were a
lot of other reasons that contributed to
it as well but all these different
reasons
coalesced into the summer of 1919 when
it was just it more or less felt like
open war against black americans to the
point that you actually saw black
americans being killed just in
streets and nobody really seemed to do
anything about it and so what you saw
was black veterans who were actually
taking up arms
against white americans and so they were
literally buying up guns they were
positioning you know people in in like
sniper spots they were fortifying
neighborhoods they were barricading cars
like they were effectively preparing
themselves for war
against white americans and so you know
eventually it all you know more or less
kind of boiled down legislation was
introduced different things along those
lines but the the red summer of 1919
was a real event it actually happened
here in the united states if you get a
chance like don't just
don't run with it based on what i said
like like check it out right like
actually read about it
it's nuts it's just a it's a crazy
moment but while this whole conversation
is going down right while this whole
conversation is happening that one of
the guys jack begins to succumb to the
effects of the super soldier serum has a
heart attack and dies right jack just
dies on the spot and so of these seven
guys
one of them is gone now and that's
actually going to be a repeating pattern
over the course of the rest of the story
that guys are just going to die by
different means right by different
situations but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end if you guys are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like that will
catch you all later
peace
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back
with the origin of isaiah bradley part
two right the truth red white and black
the story of the black captain america
okay so uh in the previous video we
basically ended with this idea that
isaiah bradley and these various other
african-americans had all been taken
by essentially the us government whisked
off to a camp that didn't really exist
in mississippi
and then basically subjected to a series
of terrible processes in order to
recreate captain america steve rogers
right because steve rogers was off
fighting in world war ii at that time
and they saw him as a success and they
suddenly wanted to create more what this
does at least this the second half this
conclusion it's going to give us a lot
of information especially what happened
to isaiah but it's also going to fill in
what was going on behind the scenes in
terms of
the fact that it's a lot more complex
than we were initially told right
so one of the first things that happens
here and this is one of the things we
talked about in the last video
is that in order to ensure that nobody
would come looking for these soldiers
that the us government had created a
cover story right and basically said
these guys had all just been killed in
like bombings and different events and
so on and so forth
now where a lot of the other individual
families ended up more or less accepting
this
faith the wife of isaiah bradley did not
she did not accept this as an absolute
truth and at the very least wanted to
see her husband's body the results of
this is that she was kind of roadblocked
every single time she tried
and every time that she was turned down
she became more and more suspicious
right that if her husband really did die
then it's like okay then like i need to
find out what's going on and when she
finally saw the body
she realized something was off right and
so what ended up happening is when she
went to go visit the military
she was kind of like okay when i saw the
body of my husband it was the charred
body of a white man so like
what in the world is going on here right
like why is my husband's body replaced
with a white guy and so we're again
she's kind of railroaded and not really
given any any actual answers outside of
the fact that he was just kind of burned
beyond
recognition uh in the end it was just
kind of you know just that's the way it
is and she was kind of sent on her way
now as she's leaving she's met by
a black member of the military who
basically tells her that what ends up
happening a lot of times i don't know
how true this is
but what ends up happening a lot of
times is that when there's bombings that
take place with regards to
you know various soldiers that usually
they're blown to pieces and that what
the government does is try to assemble
at least some variation of them
in order to actually have a body in the
casket and so they'll have like a suit
on and things like that they'll make
them look as clean as they can
but like their legs might be
disconnected or something like that you
just won't know because there's
basically they're sitting in a casket
and there's pants covering their legs
and so it's one of the things where it's
just kind of like it's the nature of
this but
what he does is kind of provide this
kind of you know
almost bottom level uh indication that
like it's a cover-up right he doesn't
really say it in so many words he
doesn't really say no don't worry like
your husband
like he didn't die in a bombing the
government's lying to you he doesn't
really say that instead it's just kind
of like well i mean you know they kind
of put them together and
and so on but it's kind of pointing to
this idea that like the body in the
casket is not your husband but instead
of just kind of leading it and saying
like it's not your husband because the
government just did the best they could
with what they had instead it's
there's something a little more
nefarious going on but the reality of
this and what she kind of walks away
from is
she's never going to get isaiah back now
the reality of her husband
is that he alongside a few other members
of the of the group
are kind of fighting out in the german
black forest right and as they're going
through and facing off against these
germans and they take these guys out
based on the assignment they were given
by the military they end up finding out
that what they were there to do was to
essentially inter-intercept a supply
line and inside one of these trucks
is a bunch of pharmaceuticals or a bunch
of uh what look like medicines from hope
pharmaceuticals now there is a huge
thing behind this and it's not what they
think it is but from their perspective
they believe it's like bandages and
medicines and there's a huge mental toll
that comes with this because they feel
like they've been sent on a mission to
essentially
intercept supply lines to keep the
germans from being able to
tend to the tender they're injured now
the reality of this is that is exactly
what happened
right i mean and not not necessarily in
the story but like in world war
ii uh that's exactly what happened there
were multiple instances
where the us military would engage in
these supply line interceptions that
were designed to basically
keep germans and italians and members of
the access access powers from being able
to tend to their wounded right it was
the one of the most effective ways of
being able to keep them from
keeping their supply lines maintained by
keeping their soldiers happy and healthy
in some ways they turn it into a war of
attrition but one of the things that
kind of goes on is that this creates a
kind of mental toll for these guys right
especially for maurice now the reason
why it matters for maurice is because
once they're there and they're basically
in
in portugal and i wouldn't really call
it r r they're just kind of between
missions at the moment uh you end up
having merit now philip merritt of
course we know is one of the guys who
was there and the
the outset of them all kind of being
rounded up and then taken to
camp cathcart and then ultimately taken
to their final destination where they
were
imbued with the super soldier serum uh
this guy's obviously racist right i mean
it's one of the things that's kind of
given he refers to them as like boys
things like that
and his racism would become a lot more
prevalent the the you know further you
get into the story but one of the things
that he does is he reveals to maurice
the fact
that his dad killed himself that his dad
killed killed his mom and then killed
himself
because when they were given the news
that maurice had been killed uh
essentially they couldn't you know he
couldn't really handle it right his dad
couldn't handle it and when maurice
learns that he immediately loses it now
what it does is it leads to maurice
actually killing one of the other guys
and then attacking merit and breaking
his collar bone and so when you have
this happening and maurice of course
essentially perishes as well basically
isaiah is the only guy left
and so what it does is it basically
leads to isaiah being the sole survivor
and then having a meeting with christ
where he's just kind of like look like
it's the nature of this thing right like
understand
if you continue doing the missions as
you're supposed to then your family will
survive
and while it's not necessarily on the
nose the message that's being delivered
here is
do what we tell you to or we'll kill
your family and then we'll kill you
right like that kind of a thing we'll
wipe it all off the face of the map
because in reality it's in the best
interest of the military to essentially
tie up all loose ends but one of the
things that's also established here
by uh by reinstein is there really not
even just reinstein but by uh walter
nagle kind of operating under the name
of jeffrey reinstein it was essentially
established that maurice had a
kind of exaggerated thyroid gland and
because of that it led to like an
increase in extreme emotional states and
that's one of the one of the the
the problems that came with this
iteration of the super soldier serum is
that again steve rogers was kind of the
perfect
the perfect serum was imbued with him
with regards to abraham erskine
everybody else like it all had some kind
of flaw to it and so if there was
already an existing exaggeration
of the thyroid gland and the super
soldier serum would enhance that at
least the way that it was made by
by weinstein it would exacerbate it and
make it worse right and so essentially
it was only a matter of time before
maurice had some kind of a psychotic
break
and then lost it the other part of this
is that you end up having isaiah being
sent on a final mission but the problem
is that when that mission goes down one
it's radio silence
but two he ends up stealing the captain
america suit now the
again steve rogers was actually alive
and fighting in world war
ii at this point in time he somebody
just didn't know what was going on this
was essentially a backup suit right and
so because of the fact that isaiah was
so enamored by the idea of captain
america and fighting on the side of
righteousness and so on he steals what
was basically the old shield of captain
america or really i guess kind of the
newer version of captain america's
shield uh combined with a backup captain
america suit and essentially becomes the
black captain america and goes racing
into what i believe is called short
speed the uh it was a german camp uh
it's specific to this story as far as
i'm aware it didn't really exist but
goes racing in there and that's his
mission now when he gets here this is
when we really kind of start to get an
explanation he takes out a few of the
german guards and those guys are done
pretty quickly
grab some exp explosives and then goes
to destroy these different warehouses
they have but his actual mission is to
essentially track down all the research
of
coke and so again we'll get a lot more
information with regards to this guy
once we get towards the end of the story
but when he gets into the laboratory he
ends up realizing that coke has been
experimenting on people now
coke's not the only person to do that
something to understand and we'll talk
more about this as again as we get
towards the end is what was going on
with regards to
uh mr sinister right nathaniel essex
who's also a part of this as well
not this particular thing but a part of
it as well but when when isaiah gets in
there he finds just all these grotesque
experiments some of which involve young
people right kids
babies different things like that the
just the depravity of it all
is so extreme and so the results of that
is he he really is kind of breaking down
and struggling the whole time
and then a whole bunch of germans you
know where a whole bunch of people are
basically being put inside of a of a
building and then he runs inside
as well slams the door shut only to find
out it's a gas chamber right and like
zyklon b is getting ready to get pumped
into this thing
and that's gonna be it right and that's
exactly what happens that once he's in
there the super soldier serum allows him
to survive the experience but he's
literally
inside this room while all these jews
are dying and so it's a little crazy
because once he starts to wake up he's
basically captured by the germans now
while that's all going on
there's a kind of explanation that's
being offered by way of
of essentially you know somebody in the
background talking to somebody else
right kind of explaining
what's going on to a degree right that
isaiah kind of realized that you can't
save everybody
things along those lines kind of
speculating to a degree on what isaiah
was thinking what he was going through
how this whole thing unfolded and so
ultimately we find out that this his
wife faith who's talking to steve rogers
basically telling captain america all
this stuff and so when he's kind of like
so isaiah's dead like isaiah died at the
camp her response is no whatever would
make you think that isaiah bradley was
dead and so from there you actually kind
of jump back a little bit right you you
are really kind of
jump back before steve rogers had this
meeting but after the whole events with
the camp and all that kind of stuff so
we're gonna have a little back and forth
here for the next little bit
but you end up having steve rogers who
basically meets with philip merritt
who's in lompoc federal prison out in
california and this takes place about
five days before the meeting that he had
with faith
and philip is a guy who's essentially
been busted on seemingly
everything right killing a federal agent
commit a conspiracy to commit acts of
domestic terrorism
gun running money laundering
racketeering i mean if he did it
he's basically been thrown in jail for
it now there is a little bit of
of indication here that some of these
charges are trumped up or fake charges
just to kind of get him removed out of
the equation
the reality is doesn't make a whole lot
of sense right i mean if the
government's good at anything it's
killing people without anybody knowing
so i have a hard time believing that if
the government wanted this guy dead they
wouldn't just kill him right so it kind
of seems to be to move him out of the
way or he's actually guilty of all this
stuff
but one of the things that he talks
about is racism really kind of comes to
comes to sharp relief when we end up
finding out that somewhere along the
line reinstein was executed right that
uh
that walter nagel was basically killed
and that when that happened it was at a
meeting that he had where he had met
philip merritt and while philip merritt
was kind of a young person in the
military
and steve rogers was kind of there with
everybody else so philip was just kind
of a guy who was there that wasn't
really of any significant notice
that when uh when when walter nagle was
killed that you ended up having somebody
who basically
raced off to his laboratory and torched
it and that's when he realizes philip
merritt was the guy who did it then he
basically betrayed the country right
that he was essentially working
alongside the germans or at least that
seemed to be the case and that's when
his racism
full-on comes out that in the warehouse
that he had there was a lot of german
propaganda and then there was also the
uh the suit of captain america that
isaiah bradley had been wearing and so
that's kind of the bunker situation is
because the more the conversation goes
down the more the philip merritt starts
talking about things
how like black americans were trying to
achieve equal rights and that let you
know black americans need to be used for
cannon fodder effectively and that the
germans had it right when they were
basically rounding up people who were
deemed to be
undesirable and then gassing them
turning them into some kind of a forced
labor working them to death whatever the
case was
but like there was no reason to believe
that black americans could in any form
or fashion be useful in
uh in society as a whole without just
being kind of thrown out there as cannon
fodder right you know and
even goes as far as to refer to isaiah
bradley as captain americoon right so
like the racism here coming from the sky
is pretty extreme now something to
understand because i'm sure a lot of
people who are kind of looking for a
reason to be mad
we'll like take this and run with it and
say like see marvel's racist that's not
really true right the important thing to
understand when it comes to period
pieces like this
it's designed to reflect one how far how
much things have changed in different
ways
and two the backwards mindsets of
various people and and then
you know to kind of illustrate that
point you do end up seeing instances
where like a racial term gets thrown in
but it's not being racist for the sake
of being racist right it's designed to
illustrate a point and so what you end
up doing is switching over to isaiah
bradley after he had essentially
you know escaped or at least you know
woken up inside of one of the gas
chambers
and he's essentially been snatched up
and brought towards the journey you know
brought to the german fury and that's
kind of the crazy thing is because what
he ends up really doing is trying to
like put forward this idea that isaiah
bradley should work for them and he
actually ends up bringing in like the
german minister of propaganda now one
thing to understand about what germany
did back in the day during world war ii
is propaganda was a huge part of the
german of the the german war effort and
in fact during events like like when
germans were when germany was taking
stalingrad right they would go through
and routinely blare right they would
just play these these
kind of broadcasts where they would tell
like the russian soldiers the soviet
soldiers like
surrender to us and we'll treat you
better than your than your leaders do
because at that point in time
uh if you were part of the red army they
would actually kill you for retreating
right which is one of the reasons why
so many russian soldiers died because
like if you they would they would just
like
send you forward and you would fight and
if you threw down your arms and you just
ran backwards you'd get killed by your
own officers right by your own your own
commanders
it was pretty backwards and it was
pretty extreme but as far as
as stalin was concerned it was the only
way to force people to fight and so
because of that you kind of have isaiah
who doesn't really take it seriously
right that the you know that girls and
those guys are kind of like hey look
like you know understand like your
people are being treated terribly in the
united states right like your people
come out of slavery right you've never
really had equal rights in comparison to
white americans you experience racism at
seemingly every turn we here in germany
we're a lot more enlightened
than america is we're far more
enlightened we're trying to do the right
thing we're trying to make the world a
better place so come side with us and
we'll take care of your people
right we'll take care of black americans
uh and it's it's
it's a tough sell if you know anything
about germany
and that's why isaiah is just kind of
like no that's not gonna happen like my
wife would kill me if i sided with the
germans so obviously he's not even
remotely taking these guys seriously
and so following that you know basically
the german fear is just like throw him
in a vehicle
you know and then we'll just we'll we'll
have him eliminated but then the
question kind of becomes like if this
guy is capable of what he's done so far
then like like the americans have been
have gotten pretty far
with coke's formula right so again kind
of an important thing going on here and
something to keep in the back of your
head now ultimately of course
isaiah is told by by the german fury hey
look uh we're gonna get you cleaned up
we're gonna treat your wounds and then
we're gonna let you go isaiah is no fool
right he's like
these guys are gonna kill me but there's
not much he can do right there's not a
whole lot that he can do there
instead what ends up happening is that
you kind of switch back to philip
merritt and the meeting that captain
america had with him
along with uh along with the the fbi
agent of course who's you know half
black or at least uh has german air in
his blood and ultimately like when they
go to leave
philip asks uh captain america to
basically give him an autograph
now captain america does but there's a
priceless to be paid for it and so while
they're leaving
you end up having this guy who starts
talking to steve rogers and saying you
know there's a story that my grandfather
or you know
grandfather klaus always told he always
told this story and it was interesting
the way this works is that
after isaiah bradley is basically taken
by the germans for the intention of
being executed
that the the convoy is essentially
knocked over right like the road to
auschwitz is
which is where he's supposed to be going
is essentially intercepted by a handful
of black soldiers and one of these guys
is the grandfather of this fbi agent and
the way this works the way it's kind of
explained to us
is that isaiah bradley had essentially
been taken by these guys
and then essentially brought into a
series of under a series of supply lines
and more or less brought back to the
united states right these are black
soldiers right these are these are our
black allied soldiers
and so it's a it's a cool thing to see
that he was he's a black captain america
saved by black americans who were
fighting during world war ii and so what
you end up doing is kind of jumping back
in
at least as far as two days ago where
you have captain america meeting with uh
with walker price now walker price
is the guy who was running that right
that military officer the guy who was a
dick uh he was the one that was running
everything
this is captain america basically
confronting him and he essentially says
like you know i want to know what's
going on here
right like i want to know everything
that's happening and and he really kind
of asked him about like
about like isaiah bradley but he says i
need to explain you know how you could
wind up running
coke international and and what you have
to do with isaiah bradley and all that
stuff and walker's response is it's all
the same story and so this is where you
kind of get this huge exposition on
what's going
on and you actually you actually learn
some really intriguing things here so
one of the first things that's
established here
is that the notion of germany using what
was in effect
uh ethnic cleansing models was based on
the united states and that's true
so to sidetrack from the story for a
second kind of dealt here in the real
world there was a guy by the name of
harry laughlin and he
basically lived or or was head of the
eugenics record office from 1910 to
1939. but important thing to understand
here is that you had in the united
states what was called the immigration
act of 1924.
back during that point in time and in
the years leading up to it the united
states practiced eugenics
the way it worked is the u.s would
basically determine what individuals
were considered the most desirable those
individuals who were
chinese and japanese were considered the
least desirable and those individuals
from like uh from from eastern europe
were considered
a little more desirable than chinese or
japanese but still
undesirable overall and so what the
united states basically did is it
created this kind of
hierarchy right those individuals who
were considered the least desirable to
the to the most desirable and that those
who were kind of classified below with a
certain threshold the us
would involuntarily sterilize them when
they came into the us they would make
sure that they couldn't have any kids
because the united states wanted to keep
america ethnically cleansed they wanted
to keep it ethnically pure and it wasn't
just the us he was also britain who did
the same thing and germany to a degree
before the before the fear and before
the the germans rose to power
before like you know everything popped
off with regards to the war
and so because of that uh the idea of
what was going on
during world war ii and the
concentration camps was rooted in what
took place in the united states that you
know as far as
as the more modern era the us kind of
spearheaded that stuff and that's one of
the things that he talks about here
right that like francis galton was the
one who came up with the idea of
eugenics in the first place
the science of improving the stock and
it was basically just
a movement in the united states to
sterilize individuals who were deemed to
be
undesirable and ensure they couldn't
procreate in the united states and taint
the gene pool that was the whole belief
of america
at that point in time it was not
believed entirely in america that's
something that i want to clarify it was
not a wholly supported movement by
everybody in the united states but those
in position of power believed it was a
good idea
one of the things that came out of this
is the super soldier project now this is
where i want to kind of wrap everything
back together
and give you guys a more clear picture
here so when you look at something like
weapons plus you look at the super
soldier project all that kind of stuff
it really all starts with nathaniel
essex mr sinister right he was a guy who
believed
that mutants were slowly rising to
prominence and individuals were
developing powers and he was curious
about how all that dna worked and so
during world war ii he operated inside
of a concentration camp performing all
kinds of heinous experiments on people
uh that he believed possessed what was a
mutant gene or trying to understand the
human genome better so he could predict
who was going to become a mutant and who
wouldn't now ultimately when the the
forces of his concentration camp were
liberated by the invaders right so
captain america bucky barnes
name with a submariner the original
human torch jim hammond that he
essentially went underground but his
research had been discovered by a guy
named truett hudson who ended up
changing his name but truitt hudson had
used all this stuff and then
created what was in effect quote unquote
the the weapons plus
project as we more or less know it today
but the precursor to the weapons plus
project and the precursor to project
wide awake came by way of like isaiah
bradley and eugenics experimenting and
understanding the human genome to
eliminate undesirable people but the
antithesis to that is
if we can eliminate undesirable people
by essentially sterilizing them
is it possible to manipulate the human
genome to create desirable people
and the germans were the ones who came
up with that kind of secondary thought
process
and that's why you saw the united states
government sending in nick fury and the
howling commandos to snatch up abraham
erskine and whisk him to the united
states for his super soldier serum which
could be used to create the perfect
super soldier
now once that project was kind of off to
the races and you had truett hudson and
all them that's when it goes into the
united states creating and using it as a
model to kind of contain and control the
mutant threat that's where the precursor
element
of project wide awake comes into play
right because it's one thing to say okay
like let's create super soldiers or
create the perfect person the perfect
being
and then like fill our society with that
but then when mutants start popping up
and there's people with extraordinary
powers
then the role of the government becomes
self-preservation and so then it's like
okay well then let's just find a way to
contain and control the mutant threat
which is
why captain america was originally
supposed to be brought back presumably
my wife and then reconditioned to go
forward and be the first of a new line
of super soldiers assuming that abraham
erskine hadn't died but again that's
that's that's how it was all kind of
supposed to play out that's kind of the
big
broad perception of it um we can do a
far more
nuanced explanation kind of run through
the whole timeline if you guys are
interested i don't remember whether we
have a video on it or not i don't
believe we do
i don't think we have a video where we
kind of explain the timeline of the
weapons plus project
the the creation of captain america all
the other weapons plus or all the other
weapons projects that were created you
know how it involves and how it brings
in like blue marvel adam brashear how it
ties in i say
isaiah bradley how it all leads into
like wolverine and then eventually
deadpool and all that kind of stuff i
don't think we've done that right so
it might be hooves to kind of do this
this huge explanation video
kind of breaking down weapons plus but
the reality is that uh the actions of
price
are really pretty heinous here right and
it's one of the things where he says
like hey yeah we did some pretty shady
things but that's just the nature of war
right it's just the way things go
uh so i mean i'm not gonna apologize for
it but the important thing is that
originally you had coke and weinstein or
or walter nagel if you want to call him
that and they were in effect the same
thing right they were kind of working on
the same project but ultimately they
were sent to the united states for the
purpose of showcasing
the ability to move eugenics beyond
simply just forced sterilization of
undesirable people and actually create
individuals who were of a higher
a higher stock quote unquote but when
the war broke out you had coke who went
back to germany and you had reinstate
who stayed here
and so the the race was basically on you
had germany trying to create their own
super soldiers and then you had the
united states trying to create theirs
and all of it came in the aftermath of
abraham erskine dying everybody was
trying to create new captain america
type
guys new super soldiers and reinstead
and coke were just a couple of examples
of that there were a lot of others who
were doing it too again truett hudson
who
eventually changed his name to abraham
cornelius uh you had all kinds of stuff
that was going on right you had all
these things that were that were playing
out but with regards to this great big
huge revelation and the fact that that
steve rogers is kind of being confronted
with the the idea
that his origin is rooted in the idea of
removing
undesirable people from society that
what we also find out that he had done
is he
had essentially you know used a whole
bunch of the money that he got in terms
of back pay from his time in the
military
and bought up enough stock options in
coke international that he can appear at
a shareholder meeting and he's bringing
the entire military record of of christ
with him and is going to dump all that
information out there right and
basically tell the world
what price is about and so because of
the fact that he's kind of the the head
of the company
that would be huge right it'd be a huge
revelation because philip merritt was
the one
that handed all that information over
and so you end up having steve rogers
you know kind of picking up in the
current moment right now steve rogers
goes and visits with faith and when that
happens you basically have them kind of
talking
leading into the moment where she you
know essentially talks about everything
that was going on with regards to isaiah
and all that kind of stuff and so once
she takes off her headdress
you know we she basically says like i
will take you to meet isaiah bradley but
there's something that you need to
understand here
right the impact of the super soldier
serum as it was given to you was a
perfected version right you are the
perfect human being as far as isaiah
bradley goes he was given an
imperfect one and so one of the side
effects of what happened is that he was
ultimately sterilized right it kept him
from being able to have any kids now
luckily for us we had a daughter
before that took place but one of the
other side effects that came from this
is he's kind of been reduced to a
rudimentary state he doesn't really
speak anymore and he's more child than
adult and so
she's like that's something that you
need to be prepared for you need to be
aware of that and so steve rogers goes
to meet with isaiah bradley and the
crazy thing about this and that's that's
one of
the cool concepts here isaiah bradley is
exceedingly well known in the black
community right within the black
community
everybody knows who isaiah bradley is
and he's met with everyone right he met
with nelson mandela he met with
met with malcolm x he met with all kinds
of people james brown all kinds of guys
right even even like bono
from you too which i don't really know
if i would call that an achievement like
bono's an [ __ ] but the fact remains
that
it's one of these things where within
the black community he's highly
celebrated right as the black captain
america and it's one of those concepts
and it's not really something that's
explored until you get into the crew but
one of the things behind isaiah bradley
is that he
is was almost considered to be a myth
right it's one of those things where
like it's a champion of the black
community that no one really knows about
that it's very very tight-knit very
closed off
and unless you're within the black
community or you know people in the
black community they're willing to tell
you about him you would never know he
even existed in the first place and so
it's kind of a crazy thing that goes on
because
steve rogers goes to visit him and and
is just kind of enamored by him right
there's a there's a lot of
sadness and guilt that goes into this
because of everything isaiah bradley had
been through that any chance of having a
full-on meaningful life was stripped by
the federal government from him
being able to achieve those things right
to go on and to see his family grow and
prosper them having more children right
all the the tormented things that he'd
seen
the kind of things he put up with you
know the fact that he lost his ability
to function on a high on a high level
and it's kind of been reduced to a child
who's also been sterilized steve rogers
takes a lot of guilt with this you know
and while it's not necessarily steve
rogers fault directly the fact that he
didn't know that there was a black
counterpart to himself out there
is something that he struggles with and
so he really is here in a lot of ways to
make amends and to say you know as a
person who represents what are supposed
to be
the greatest ideals of america america
has failed you
has failed you in the worst way and so
while i can't make up for that in the
most grand sense what i can do
is try to bring at least some merit of
satisfaction to your life and so what he
does is he actually gives him
the old captain america uniform that he
wore the one that he wore during world
war ii which brings a huge amount of
happiness
to to isaiah bradley right and the two
of them end up getting a bit of a
picture together that's taken by faith
and that's where the story ends
uh but isaiah bradley's story is amazing
that's why i told you guys truth red
white and black is amazing and here's a
funny thing you guys were the ones who
told me about it beforehand
i didn't initially know this existed
right i was like what in the world and
then and then you guys were like like i
want to say maybe a year or two ago you
guys were like you should cover truth
red white and black and it really is a
great
story right it's an incredibly great
story so yeah isaiah bradley this is his
origin guys
this is this is the origin of this guy
and it's cool so with that being said
guys we're going to bring this video to
an end if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob poor if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace